[Music]
not only will you have to build a radio
you'll also need to construct a radio
tower that's two meters tall and strong
enough to support a two kilogram
satellite dish once your radio is built
you'll then use that to tune into stem
FM
good morning everyone I'm so excited to
prepare you for the challenges ahead
they're going to be really difficult but
we're going to give you the underlying
principles that will really help you
understand not just how to succeed in
these challenges but what's actually
going on underneath things so the
underlying principle for today's
challenge is radio waves radio waves are
a kind of electromagnetic radiation and
you've probably heard about that idea
before but I really want to dive deep
into how these Concepts work so let's
think about this and compare all the
different kinds of electromagnetic
radiation that we have you probably know
some of them right so I'm going to use
this kind of as a plot to think about up
here higher energy higher frequency
radiation so I'll just sort of label
that for us so we know where we're going
and if there's a higher frequency
and higher energy that means there's
more power going in and uh you know more
power coming out depending on like
what's actually standing in the front of
all of this radiation right and right
here in the middle of what we call the
electromagnetic spectrum is a tiny
little sliver in here which is what our
eyes can actually see so does anyone
know what we call that little part of
the spectrum
yeah fantastic so all these visible
wavelengths hidden in here this is what
our eyes are geared to experience right
it says all this electromagnetic
radiation but this is part that you can
see now you probably know the colors of
a rainbow right do you know them do you
know the order do you have the acronym
in your head come on let's do it
together it's red orange yellow green
blue indigo violet you're like rojib
it's in there somewhere okay so well
done you nailed it if we have a think
about the visible spectrum so we've got
our roygbiv here inside tucked inside
the visible spectrum but what I want us
to do is think about well what's what's
going on in the rest of here because
today's challenge is not about the
visible way of making spout somewhere
else that we use to communicate so let's
first go up right remember we said that
there's Violet at the top here right so
we have a word that just means what
happens when you go above Violet do you
know what that word is ultraviolet right
so we've got UV in here and then when we
say okay remember we're going higher
energy higher frequency and so on right
after ultraviolet which we know if if
we're in the sun we get all this UV on
us right we can get burnt Etc but after
that we've got particular parts of
radiation that will go right through
your body except for your bones your
bones will stop them what's that next
part called that's right x-rays very
good and fun fact you know when x-rays
are first discovered people were kind of
like what are these Rays they're kind of
strange and unknown what do we call them
extra unknown right there's one last
part that goes up above here the highest
kind of radiation that we know about
just like this can burn you this could
cause you some serious problems if
you're exposed to a lot apparently this
will turn you into a enormous green
raging monster right does anyone know
what's the last one gamma rays fantastic
so gamma rays are very high energy
and very dangerous like properly
dangerous right they can mess around
with your DNA if you're exposed to too
much usually usually comes from
radioactive decay or even like a nuclear
explosion or things like that okay
so these are higher energy so we know
these are pretty dangerous thankfully we
are not going to be working with any of
those today we're actually going to go
sort of down below okay now we said
ultra violet is above Reds at the bottom
of the spectrum so what's our word for
underneath red infrared infrared
fantastic and that's literally what
infra means now all of us are actually
giving off electromagnetic radiation and
the main kind that we give off is
infrared because we're all warm-blooded
I mean presumably none of you glow in
the dark not giving you a visible light
okay but you are giving off ir and
obviously if you have the right camera
you know night vision goggles that's
exactly what we would see even if it was
Pitch Black okay now let's keep going
down right underneath IR this is kind of
thermal it's heat right we've got
something that doesn't feel warm but it
can make things warm you've probably got
one of these in your house does anyone
know what's next very good microwaves
are down here
and the whole idea of how microwaves
work is they can also penetrate through
materials but as they go through if
there's water molecules inside you or
food or things like that then they're
actually going to get excited they'll
vibrate and that's how we heat our food
well that's one of the ways right now
like I said right at the top the real
kind of electromagnariation we're most
interested in is the final one down here
right after radio waves it's got the
lowest frequencies right and so it's the
lowest energy we call them radio waves
right and there's many kinds of radio
waves the kind that we're interested in
you might have noticed as you walked in
you walked past something that's right
at the top of that radio wave spectrum
what kind of radio do you think it was
because there's at least two kinds right
and they come with acronyms anyone know
I am an FM AM and FM very good so we've
got FM radios which is the kind that
you're going to be building and then am
which we still use today but it's a
slightly older technology and you can
see why it's it's lower power you can
make an AM radio very easily even like a
teeny tiny battery will do the job but
we're going to be working in FM today
okay now like we did you sort of zoomed
in here if we zoomed right in to FM what
you get here
is different kinds of frequencies that
can be accessed right for FM there's a
range of from the top to the bottom
88 megahertz all the way up to
108 megahertz I don't know if any of you
guys listen to actual FM radio but
that's that range there right it's why
all the station numbers are like what
are they
97.3 106.9 they're all in this range now
it's it's Mega Hertz does anyone know
what hertz actually means
or what it measures sound it's it can
measure sound actually what it measures
is sort of on the board I gave you a bit
of a clue what do you reckon severe
maybe like waves per second yeah very
good so it's it's this idea here waves
per second how frequently something is
happening right uh Hertz was a scientist
who worked in the space so we named this
idea after him this unit
one Hertz means there's a wave and the
frequency of it is one per second so for
example if we were to draw I wonder if
you guys can tell me what kind of wave
is this do you know what this is called
from bats sine waves this is a sine wave
right so all kinds of frequencies here
all kinds of radiation all have this
same sinusoidal wave which by the way
let's just pause for a second it's not
wild like cyan this comes from right
angle triangle trigonometry where is
that here and the answer is it's kind of
woven into the universe right so one of
these if you've got one of these per
second that would be one Hertz
what's m Mega mean
million that's Millions right so this
would be right at the bottom here 88
million of these per second
it's quite a few and then remember like
we're all the way down here at radios
can you imagine how high the frequencies
are for here and that's why they can do
so much damage right so when we think
about this FM and AM
the F stands for frequency so we're
measuring how frequently does that wave
go and I want to guess what the a in am
stands for it's something else on this
graph altitude is very very close yeah
it's like it's this it's the same idea
altitude and amplitude is like how high
up and down do these things go right so
am is measuring this FM is measuring
this okay now this is the underlying
principle underneath what you're doing
today okay you are going to be
trying to build something that she's
going to receive from this and I just
want to show you physically how this
works okay so let me give you a couple
of different metaphors for this
we're pretty experienced with the idea
of waves from music right and from sound
okay so as you sound is not on here this
is about a that's audio okay but it's a
little illustration that I want to show
you obviously any musical instrument can
make a lot of different notes right so
for example if we just play you know
there's like a scale so I can make any
note that I like on this but if I strike
a note without holding on to a fret say
this this is the E string
[Music]
resonant frequency of that string down
the bottom and you can see how it's a
very thin string there if I strike this
other E string which is up the top of
the guitar
same note
but octaves down right and that's
because
being a thickest tree it its frequency
is lower it's it can't move as fast
physically right a thinner string it can
move faster make a higher pitch this
idea of natural resonant frequency oh
I can hear that
actually works in Reverse if I could
don't worry I'm not going to sing that
same note back to the guitar that exact
note
that string would actually vibrate in
response to me vibration causes sound
sound causes vibration right and that's
exactly how
your FM receiver that you're going to
build is going to work it's going to
vibrate for a particular kind of
frequency now my last illustration for
this involves again a bit of
electromagnetic radiation
here we go okay
right now we have all of these radio
waves going all around us hundreds and
thousands of them right and so it's like
there's a mixture a bit like this light
that you can see on here is a mixture of
different lights notice White
white is not a color on the Spectrum
what is white
yeah we've mixed them all together okay
now what you want to do is try and sift
out all of the different colors and say
where's the one that I want so in fact
what you're going to build is kind of an
electronic equivalent of saying here
is a filter
that is going to just take the
particular frequencies that I want and
rather than just have all of this noise
all together it's going to enable you to
pick up a signal that will be how you
succeed in this challenge
so
the underlying principle of this
challenge is all about radio waves you
can see where they fit on the
electromagnetic spectrum we've got all
these different things these you can see
things that affect the world around you
and we're going to build a receiver
that's right here in this special range
good luck it's going to require teamwork
and a lot of tough thinking but I'm
absolutely confident you'll be ready
and I'm like oh my God so if you break
this right now I'm joining blue team
[Music]